hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 7
video they went full Old Yeller there's
all kinds of Justice League references
from the comics so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
this week's DC giveaway is also still
open all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just for a $20 Amazon gift
card I'm doing an arrow video tomorrow
about the Graham so I'll just leave the
giveaway open til then so here we go top
5 WTF and a whole bunch of comic book
Easter eggs here we go starting with
number 5 can draw Rose space pirates so
if you're not familiar with can jar
broke
he's a Justice League villain from
pretty early in their Silver Age run he
debuted in Justice League number 3 and
just like the team was captured in this
episode the title of the story can JA
Rowe appeared in was called slaveship of
space number 4 meet Eve Baxter super
judgy fellow time master she seems like
a TV show version of the Bonnie Baxter
character who's from the classic Time
Master stories she debuted and showcased
number 20 in 1959 in what a coincidence
that the team is going back to 1958 in
next week's episode next week's episode
is like a Stepford Wives episode but
I'll talk about that at the end of this
video number 3 WTF the vanishing point
this is actually where the base of the
time masters is but in the comics there
was also a storyline called vanishing
point where rip hunter assembles a team
to go back in time and find Batman it
happened right after Final Crisis Batman
was seemingly killed by Darkseid's Omega
beams but really the Omega beams sent
him back in time so rip hunter assembled
a team to figure out where the hell he
went in the context of the episode
though it's meant to be the time masters
base when the location first debuted in
the comics it was actually Adventures of
Superman number 476 way back in 1991 and
it was the base of the linear meant he
was just this alternate dimension that
existed outside of time and space that
allowed the linear men a team that rip
hunter belonged to with Waverider and
allowed them to police the time stream
so I know it's a little confusing
because rip hunter is part of the time
masters but he was also part of the
linear men in the comics think of the
linear men is like a subset of the time
masters but not officially connected so
the TV show is just blending a couple
comic book things number two WTF heat
wave finally goes rogue and turns on the
team for most of the episode I thought
he was bluffing the Pyrus and he would
double-cross them
the end of the episode but then we got
the old yeller WTF at the end of the
episode so I don't know what's going on
now I don't know if heatwave is
completely gone I don't think that they
would kill the character off completely
like Hawkman he's dead right now on the
show he's totally gonna come back
because it's a time-travel show so I
assume heat wave is gonna come back too
for that was actually my number one WTF
all deal with it
captain cold puts Old Yeller down or
seemingly does the TV show really wants
you to think that he's dead the title of
the episode is marooned
we don't know what time period they left
heatwave in but the story captain cold
told to Sarah about how he and heatwave
became friends the first time and how
heatwave always looked out for him just
made me think the captain cold found a
way to maroon heatwave instead of
killing him but they definitely want you
to think that he's dead just because of
the way they cut at the end of the
episode stray observations space Rangers
star Martin Stein he was completely on
fire that'll teach you to mess with a
physicist he's a total badass but his
childhood hero Space Ranger star is an
actual DC character from the 1950s he
debuted in showcase number 15 in 1958
that was around the same time that the
bonny Baxter character debuted so a lot
of their names and references are coming
from the showcase comics the really old
DC comics that are set in space the DC
version of the character is actually
based on an even older version of a
Space Ranger a David Starr Space Ranger
character created by Isaac Asimov in
this 1952 novel so you could say when
Martin Stein is invoking space Rangers
star he could be referencing the Isaac
Asimov version or the DC Comics version
usually I assume all the comic book
references are DC specific unless it's
like Star Trek or Star Wars and there
was a whole bunch of Star Trek in this
episode Captain's Log
I guess if Ray is Captain Kirk that
makes Hawkgirl Spock but then captain
cold calls him Picard and he's like no
I'm more like Sulu right now no wait no
wait Han Solo I'm Han Solo other stray
observations before the episode aired I
saw this picture of this other pirate
here and was like wait a minute is this
supposed to be one of the children of
Vandal Savage he's dressed like Vandal
Savage his face looks very similar to
Vandal Savage from the comics when they
say that the time masters have to use
fake names to protect their families to
protect the ones that they love rip
hunter is not his real identity he is
secretly the son of Booster Gold Booster
Gold actually ends up finding
is out he meets rip hunter then later
learns that rip hunter is his son and he
learns that he has to be a douchebag in
order to save the world Booster Gold
actually a pretty big hero but he's
affectionately thought of is the most
lovable douchebag in the DC Universe the
name of that story was Booster Gold
futures and it happened right around
convergence the other Timeship has a
Gideon AI only it's named Gilbert so I'm
guessing it's either like Siri or each
of them have very distinct personalities
maybe you didn't see the preview for
next week's episode it's gonna be a
little Pleasantville a little Stepford
Wives those are both kinda sci-fi
stories but I'll say I think the only
thing in this week's episode that didn't
feel like it worked for me was rip
hunters relationship with his wife
Miranda liked the flashback scenes it
just felt like they didn't have a lot of
chemistry they haven't spent a lot of
time developing that relationship I feel
like when he was watching the recording
that was great you get the sense that he
is cracking under pressure I totally get
the psychosis Arthur Darvill is doing an
amazing job and scenes like that and
speaking of legends of tomorrow season
two the actor that played Connor Hawke
in last week's episode said that he
might be coming back it might be a part
of season two he doesn't know anything
official he just knows that the writers
on legends of tomorrow really like his
character and want to bring him back in
a bigger way let me know in the comments
which other characters do you want to
see cycled in for season two like vixen
Constantine Connor Hawke a lot of it
will depend on what the big overarching
story is because season 1 is all about
Vandal Savage they've tied him to
Hawkman and Hawk girl's origin story so
the seasons all about them so if you
want vixen and Constantine to come on in
season 2 it has to be a magic based
villain that you do a TV show version of
Justice League dark that'd be amazing
you could bring in dr. fate it'd be
crazy in related news though like I said
I'm gonna do an arrow video about who's
in the grave there's a grave scene
pictures have a leak people think that
it's Laurel that's not really what's
going on so I'll totally explain in that
arrow video why you guys wait for me to
post that video you can click here to
learn all about the Suicide Squad sequel
that's right they've already started
working on the second movie even though
the first one hasn't come out yet and
you can click here for my zoom flash
video that I just posted thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight